[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for coming another
effectively sold-out house
blinded by the light I can't see any of
you so I would ask you all sorts of
questions about how many of you have
been before and how many of it's your
first show but I can't see any of you
even if I try so we'll pass on that but
I want to talk about loss you know I've
had my differences with the title lost
landscapes because I don't like to dwell
on loss and because history may move in
retrograde but in general it just moves
forward and we can't go back but we have
lost a great deal in San Francisco we've
lost much of our neighborhood feel we've
lost our working-class communities we've
lost most of our african-american
community due to displacement and
gentrification and while we can't go
back this is a moment where we might at
least start to think about how we can
begin to get some something back what we
want the city that we'd like to live in
so this is the ethos behind lost
landscapes as I know you've heard me say
before it isn't just about the past it's
also about the future think about the
kind of city you'd like to live in think
about the kind of world you'd like to
live in and use these images as a guide
you the audience as always or the
soundtrack I want you to identify people
places and events that you recognize I'd
like you to ask questions of your
neighbors then of me although who knows
I'd like you to engage in spirited
discussion and conflict with those
around you and I want you to have a
great time thanks so much
[Applause]
so this is footage that comes to us
through the courtesy of Jean Anderson I
believe this is some of his relatives
this I think was shot by the Nelson
family correct me if I'm wrong Jean yes
yes so I should explain this is the key
system train from Oakland to San
Francisco on the lower deck of the
bridge
maximum 45 miles an hour
definitely a better view no worries
about leakage
we're on the lower deck two decks for a
two lanes four trucks and then the
trains this started in 1939 and ended in
58
[Music]
[Applause]
we're coming into the beautiful Transbay
terminal
private it's a long story to ended up
being part of the transit systems that
were destroyed by the auto industry
first admission
1970s
no talking aloud
[Applause]
this was shot off the screen in the 70s
and it's filled with moralizing and bad
plots but it's a great view of the city
during time of change Pacific telephone
building in the background by itself
this is a theatrical feature film
outtake 35 millimeter nitrate negative
transferred at the Internet Archive
[Music]
[Applause]
notice the outdoor advertising
shot in the 1951 or there abouts
[Music]
this is from the Jones family from Long
Beach California about 1954 visiting the
city this film comes to us through the
courtesy of Carrie White Allah who's in
the audience I think unfortunately or
fortunately buzz in the film Gate
forever so we're in the early-mid I
think this is about 1934 it's kind of
the reverse of the famous Market Street
film from 1906 but this is here to just
um let us revel in the detail
this film is an outtake from well was
shot for an unknown feature film it
might have been shot on spec by
Hollywood camera people
I love the sign
that was on Third Street we just passed
by the old examiner building
1944 or 45 on the roof downtown
you know cable cars don't change very
much but they make great punctuation
[Music]
pure water sometime in the late 30s or
very early 40s
[Applause]
that's a glimpse of the Holtz family
we'll see more of them and they're also
here tonight this as some of you may
remember as an outtake from guess who's
coming to dinner it is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
everybody looks so guilty so furtive so
this is a rockefeller visiting when he's
running for president in 68 and I'm
showing this cuz he's got the Berkeley
barb this is about 1914 on the Barbary
Coast Jackson Street we don't know much
if anything about this clip if any of
you have any ideas please get in touch
who these people might be some of them
are obviously performers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right
now this footage may have had something
to do with her cells cafe founded by
Luke Purcell and Sam Kay former Pullman
porters but first called a different
club at 5:20 Pacific
um purse else was caught black-and-tan
club because both black and white people
were welcomed as patrons and was also a
taxi dance place where you would buy a
token and dance with a woman I believe
that was invented in San Francisco oh
yeah under construction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't get too nostalgic
so this is 1914 and led by the the
Treasury Department and the California
Department of I got to get this right on
State Board of Pharmacy they're burning
opium and paraphernalia on the street
there had been
there had been a drug war going on for
many many years and it was many people
welcomed the earthquake because it
leveled the Chinese opium dens and
there's a feeling that comes out of you
know really colonialism that it was good
that it was better if people prevented
Chinese people from using opium so in a
sense it was a drug war that was Anna
kind of an excuse to to to to play upon
and control this community but
interestingly enough in the Pacific
pharmacists at the time it said it is
much to be regretted that smoking opium
must be destroyed as it seems a wanton
waste it's also a pity that the opium
pipes are all destroyed they could make
interesting museum exhibits but they
staged this for the newsreel cameras in
1914 this is a Civic Center
that's right
feature outtake
I have no context for this this is also
from the Nelson family I believe it's
around 1938 and I think that they're
raising money possibly for Chinese more
relief than the war against Japan
unlike many history projects this
project begins with the material it
begins with the footage and then we have
to figure out as much as we can about
what it means where it's from what's
happening I think they're raising money
for war relief here I could be mistaken
anybody translate
you see there's a Japanese businesses in
Chinatown at the time
this is footage from a family in in
Berkeley that kind of saw themselves as
news people because they recorded a lot
of historical events that took place
around them
some tourists home movies from right
around the same time a little later 1939
save the life dance maybe this is a
early world war 2 actually you know how
you tell World War 2 footage right you
see the ration stickers in the
windshield the gas rationing stickers
we'll see some
the 50s
Grant Avenue
so remember the existential running man
many of you have seen this man before
for a long time we didn't know what he
was running from for where he was
running to and now I'm happy to say that
because of new discoveries in the
internet archives footage library we can
actually present a little more of this
existential man's existential hero's
story so here goes
so then he runs up the hill looking
behind them we don't know what movie
this is from maybe one of you movie
buffs can solve this problem ask ad
molar I thought she said that is Eddie
Muller but no but what's Alice Getti
okay that clip we've seen but this we
haven't guns running for the cable car
take two and then the rest is veiled in
history maybe he's the in that elevator
going up that we saw a little while ago
and this looks like a background process
plate that it's not
this is war time driving around in San
Francisco it's a family named Penn
Philly
I'm lyft I think in El Cerrito and they
shot some really beautiful stuff
heading down Broadway I think to the to
the water and this is the waterfront
during it says on the can the 1934
strike but I think it's the 36 strike
and you see ships idled men hanging
around sheds on the waterfront striking
workers I think this is the 36
waterfront strike it could be 34 we'll
have to do some more research
back when San Francisco was a you know a
total maritime town these um the place
where workers are sheltering these
strikes really cut at the heart of the
economy here's trucks waiting because of
picket lines to unload again around 36
this is now South Beach
there's a key system train going over
the bridge also South Beach and I miss
the 76 Union Bob there's a little
dangerous to set your watch by it but it
was great Rad's Java house and Tony's
now I think we go to photo galleries and
get our WordPress support from those
peers the Embarcadero Freeway
doesn't have beautiful back when the
ferry building housed the World Trade
Center our World Trade Center
we have a schedule in the library
regular service does SFO and Oakland
airports and those of you who've seen
this know that you gotta hang on to your
seats
[Music]
[Music]
that was an outtake from the lineup in
1957 is there aquatic park late 40s or
early 50s it appears
top right yep yes we have footage of
them playing in the 70s as well probably
not the same guys
take your daughter to work
underground newspapers for sale
[Music]
2017
so this is in 1939 lots of smokey
fairies
now watch carefully the the cyclone
fence there because in a minute we're
going to see the worker
I'm starting to hang the cables
[Music]
remember this if you ever have to build
a bridge and the bridge is very soon to
open it's a week or two away and our
family from the East Bay courtesy of
Jean Anderson is is on the bridge
watching it get paved there's a
remarkable amount of home movies shot by
people who managed to get on to the
bridges while they were being built it's
kind of like it was almost open but I
mean it was a bit I guess the workers
had a lot of family and friends
tightening the jord the joints around
the cable that cable you can see all the
individual strands that's what should
trust your life too
this is what you're looking down at
and this is a little later in the day on
opening day of the Bay Bridge the
ceremonies are over and the traffic jams
are done so our family from the East Bay
decides to go across to San Francisco I
don't know what kind of car is that man
sitting in the rumble seat sightseer is
watching the tolls get taken
notice the two-way traffic
no a couple years later that's what I
like people coming back they could miss
their ride back and a little bit of
Rincon he'll there's guy place in the
background that's my my sister friend
the honorary brother from guy plays yeah
cheering and one of really our favorite
clips from 1978 remember this this was
when um New Year's Eve workers would
throw their old desk calendars out the
window
[Applause]
and welcome
when Robert Redford was shooting his
movie the candidate they shot on this
day so as to get a free ticker tape
parade now building windows don't open
that's right it's not snow it's paper
the city sent one man
[Applause]
these are outtakes from a film made in
1953 called no escape a low-budget
feature there's the Talon ooze that
showed newsreels and and news footage
watch the traffic light carefully some
glamour images of the Civic Center
during the War World War two
the beloved Fox Theater now the Fox
Plaza so these films come from the Holtz
family through the courtesy of Edina
Roush worker who's in the audience I
think with her mother Barbara Holtz the
relatively new federal building and the
relatively old State Building and the
famous building at 8th and market built
on the site of the old vegetable market
where's that 7th in market where is that
8th and market all right we are it's
July 12 1964 and 40,000 people are
marching down a market to protest the
selection of Senator Barry Goldwater as
the Republican nominee this is a civil
rights march shot by the Holts family
and it's a march for civil rights and
for Human Rights
and culminating at the hotel where I
think a lot of delegates were staying I
like this shot that's coming up though
well that's pretty good
here's some footage of the
haight-ashbury shot by a travel
filmmaker from the Michigan Automobile
Club in 1966 or 7
ready for anything
and now it's the early 50s and we're
going to be visiting with the family
from the Portola district off of San
Bruno Avenue with modern conveniences
like the electric cigarette lighter this
is uh this is the San Bruno Avenue
off-ramp of 101 I this is a very
beautiful family and if anybody ever can
help us figure out who they are I'd love
for them to get their movies back these
came from on eBay from someplace in
Oregon their daughter is having a
ceremony today
and now we're home there's the movie
screen
this is um I believe Sylvia's birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
time for coffee with your cake it's
homogenized and a few shots of their
kitchen getting ready for Thanksgiving
this is a among my favorite to see
yeah that's a good thought I know a
little more about that
[Music]
you know I originally thought it was
late 40s but I think it's early 50s 51
to 53 it's my guess
[Applause]
and now opening up presents
[Applause]
this is another family with the maybe
not so great a house but an amazing view
I feel like this is around maybe 14th
Avenue in the sunset
um and I don't know where this is but I
just love these interiors this is a
filmmaker you know so Paul has is I'm
assuming I shouldn't there's a lot of
great sort of geeky accessories some
Kodak boxes this could be Bernal Heights
from the view
hah yeah this is different from the
other
so our East Bay family is visiting
Treasure Island but the fair is under
construction and it's still naked
landfill this is kind of a
future-oriented piece of footage as we
contemplate a new high-rise community on
Treasure Island
that's one of the hangars that still
exists
a few years before this was well really
even a year before this was just you
know mud with protected by a berm of
some sort it's not even dry at this
point
who knows where did the the landfill for
Treasure Island come from from where
dredge dredge from the bay and the ferry
leaves to go back brief images of the
Labor Day parade from 1938 we've seen
some of these in the past and so I'm
focusing just on a few of the kind of
interesting the Musicians Union our
family news they were performers here's
one of our musicians skywriting for
Labor Day let's bring that back the
actors Union
[Music]
Yeah right
the bartenders Union
[Applause]
bottled service
[Music]
the the makeup Union to keep milady
beautiful by the makeup artists I don't
know who they are
this was a Mooney Billings of freedom of
the labor martyrs and KY A's labor
programming beautiful 30s graphics aha
that's a union as well though the
International Longshore and warehouse
Union Local 1000 1-10 the first one that
played a big role in bringing us the
middle class in America and then this
rather odd men with flags and women with
flags and this is the American Guild of
variety artists
pictures say it all quite a variety of
roles there the the International ladies
garment workers union these are union
maids and of course beer brings beer
creates prosperity
[Applause]
and then
[Applause]
you're so sophisticated
[Music]
and finishing up at the shaving parlor
now I'm Douglas Corrigan also known as
wrong-way Corrigan visited San Francisco
remember he's the guy that flew from the
West Coast in New York and then filed a
flight plan to go back but instead flew
to Ireland and said that he really
didn't know what he was doing and for
the rest of his life he never admitted
that it was a what he did so he became
kind of an anti hero
cultural hero he's wearing the same
leather jacket that he flew in and the
the title is an allusion to the fact
that Lindbergh never acknowledged his
achievement but you see he's getting
mobbed here on Market Street with his
put a mortar board on him and this is
the scrap metal demonstration the
boycott of um Chinese Chinese community
groups United Chinese societies trying
to get a boycott going against shipping
scrap metal to Japan to be used in the
war against China this is um and here is
more footage from our friends the pan
Philly family this is world war two and
they're about to go on the bridge and
the only reason I'm showing this is
because it's another one of these great
transgressive home movies watch the sign
on the right carefully that says the
taking of photographs from bridge is
prohibited and of course they're
shooting you know the battleships so
does that patriotic or what I don't know
anything about this family but I'm their
sunset family I think and like one of my
holy grails I always loved is when I see
houses in the sunset next to empty lots
or next to dunes sometimes planted over
sometimes not there's a tiny bit of that
here before all the spaces were filled
in ultimately in the 70s so yeah that's
some natives probably native San
Francisco
grass and their family somewhere a
little further in town with a newborn
this is in the 30s 38 39
that was on comes from the Laval family
there's about six Lavelle's in the
audience tonight and now we're in the
richmond district this is 25th near
Balboa and here we are at Geary and
Parker in the late 50s early 60s this is
the Pioneer scooter club this was a
famous scooter club that was in Life
magazine and they actually kind of like
I don't want to say like critical mass
but they fought for scooters rights this
is the live wall Vespa dealer as I said
it Erie and Parker so there's some
beauty shots and then there's this one
guy who we're gonna see who is a big
wheel in the Pioneer scooter club who I
think was named Warren Carver we'll see
Warren in just a moment but the Pioneer
scooter club actually you know they did
they rode onto the bridges and they
wrote around town and they engaged in
demonstrations for safe
scooter lanes and for parking we'll see
a little more of that in a minute when
they start riding but right now these
are these sort of hipsters of their time
I guess
hidden stories of the Richmond
I might be mr. wall there's the Coronet
in the background I think famous movie
theater star wars premiered this guy
maybe Warren Carver
or this guy
there's just the vaguest vaguest sense
of outlaw nough surround this very very
refined balloons and all
sideshow of 60s that's right get that
angle just right
right so there's this council safe
scooter parking
I haven't really done the research yet
you know whether they were
whether they're any arrests or anything
but you see there's there's some look of
people out there this is like maybe
McAlister or something I don't know well
if you google it you get the feeling
that it was there was but I think
Sanford's the pioneers were kind of a
vanguard here we aren't by the opera
house I think kind of regrouping okay so
I notice on Friday that what's up-dock
is playing at the Castro here it is
being shot at 23rd in Balboa these again
are Holt's family movies thank you so
much for this this is a scene which I
gather is sort of meant to be a parody
of Bullitt you know with the chases up
and down the hills and it apparently
it's kind of intricate it took quite a
while to shoot the actors look just a
bit burned out but we've rarely seen
such excitement in
so this is Barbara Streisand and Ryan
O'Neal remake of bringing up baby
directed by Peter Bogdanovich
and this is 1972 I should I should say
Yeah right that's McDonough venture
[Music]
the old DeYoung the old Academy of
Sciences and here's our animal sequence
a little some calves bison taking bath
there are reasons why we no longer do
this
I wonder if would the would the Holts
family be able to explain what's
happening here
man in his boat come closer
now I want you to look closely at what
she takes out of her purse
bill see the ration sticker by the way
on the right Ocean Beach before the sand
pushed up against the Playland our
amusement park that closed in 1972
somebody want to explain the water line
cut me in the water intake right
I call this image patience
patience I don't it whether it's I think
it's military it doesn't say good year
it was probably via the makin a bit
moffett field's this is our family from
the Portola celebrating at the beach
portala that's right I know I'm not a
native thank you
[Applause]
this is sutras the successor to Sutra
baths
inside outtakes from the movie the
lineup in 1957 the sky tram behind the
Sutro Baths
great highway
the gas station now gone right by a by
where on the seal rocks Motel is across
the street seal rocks in
some picnicking
and these are Holt's children riding the
rides at Playland and this is just sort
of a survey of some of the kid-friendly
attractions at Playland
[Laughter]
[Music]
the coffee shop 20 cents
[Music]
you know what they say about how San
Franciscans used to dress quite formally
and flight hacker pool in the last this
is about 1951 actually and now it's
November 15 1969 this is the San
Francisco moratorium the big anti-war
March they were marches held all over
the United States San Francisco I think
there were 50,000 and this is footage
that comes to us through the courtesy of
Starr Sutherland veteran producer and
artist third street right there and this
what's wonderful about this footage
which was shot on super 8 I think is
that it's a an incredible view of just
the faces of people who came out against
the war in 1969
so this was a march from downtown
through the Richmond and then into the
park kind of the canonical route and
this is um general Hershey bar I was a
performance artist from LA who would
show up at all the demos I'm forgetting
his real name there's a lot about him
online
we just recently found a film he made in
Los Angeles which is an amazing collage
film which we're going to give to the
world shortly Geary many many tens of
thousands people some solidarity in the
Richmond District
[Applause]
that's the poster
[Applause]
NLF flags the American flag with a piece
of more helium balloons being
this was the age of um someone sometimes
chaotic Verity
and that was the weekend and then it's
Monday and people go back to work
this is actually a few years later in
the very early 70s after Bart opened up
one of the downtown stations and then
the far west side of San Francisco is
the Farallon ace located in district 1
not a lot of people but many hundreds of
thousands of birds and sea lions and
seals and sharks and this is where we
end on the far west of the city thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much see you next year
thank you Rick two major announcements
before you go one is that all the
members should come up on stage for the
member photo the other one is that all
major news organizations have called it
for Jones
[Applause]
[Music]